welt den besten observatorien der welt
ist bisher ein blick ins innere der
sonne verwehrt geblieben trotz
verzweifelter versuche seit mehr als 40
jahren nun hat es ein forscherteam
erstmals geschafft und ihre erkenntnis
ist mehr als überraschend der sonnen
kern dreht sich deutlich schneller als
die sonnenoberfläche selbst wie und
warum der song kern so schnell rotiert
und welche antworten diese entdeckung
auf die vielen fragen zur evolution
unseres sterns liefern kann jetzt
wirklich zum 26 herzlich willkommen
dass es noch viele offene fragen zu
unserer sonne gibt und dass sie
vielleicht sogar viel zu komplex sind um
wie eines tages komplett zu verstehen
wurde astrophysikern fast täglich
schmerzlich vor augen geführt die zu
ungenau blieben bisher ihre messungen
und deren analysen so hatten wir nur so
eine leise ahnung von ihrem aufbau
nämlich dass das sonnen innere in
verschiedenen schichten aufgeteilt ist
die wii jeweils gegenseitig beeinflussen
wie sonnen materie rotiert
unterschiedlich schnell abhängig von
tiefe und breitengrad und sorgt damit
für eine gewisse ladung in sonnen
inneren zudem hatten astrophysiker und
flüssigeren bereits seit 28 jahren nur
vermutet dass sich das innere der sonne
schneller dreht abdecken
doch der eindeutige beweis dafür blieb
aus obwohl diese spannende frage
beispielsweise aufschluss zur entstehung
der sonne selbst geben könnte dieses
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
in form auf erteilung der côte d'azur
jetzt endlich gelungen nach mehr als 40
jahren intensiver forschung zitat es ist
wirklich wunderbar auf diese weise
erstmals in den kern unserer sonne zu
blicken und zum ersten mal indirekt
seine rotationsgeschwindigkeit zu messen
sagt einer der beteiligten
wissenschaftler für ihre studie hat das
forscherteam aus frankreich die
messdaten des satelliten soll alles
fertig observatoriums so aus insgesamt
16 jahren analysiert auch das
spezialinstrument golf global operations
and low frequency was in der lage ist
schwingungen in der sonnenatmosphäre zu
messen wurde für diesen indirekten
blick in die sonne eingesetzt das
konkrete ergebnis der selbst die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
staunen die sonnenoberfläche übrigen
6000 grad halt braucht für eine drehung
um den äquator 25 tage nahe den polen
der sonne sogar 35 tage der sonnen kern
dreht sich nach berechnung des
forscherteams dagegen einmal pro woche
um sich selbst also viermal schneller
die schwierigkeit für die
französischen wissenschaftlerin
wissenschaftler bestand konkret darin
die verborgenen langweiligen schwere
wellen der sonne
die sogenannten die modi herauszufiltern
zu extrahieren
damit auch ihre existenz eindeutig zu
belegen kurz zur erklärung der begriff
schwere wellen meint wellen die sich in
einem medium wasser oder gas befinden
und von schwerkraft dominiert werden
beispielsweise wellen im meer diese
schwere wellen im kern inneren
wechselwirken wohl mit den schwingungen
in der sonnenatmosphäre so die
mutmaßung des forscherteams der plan
bestattungen daraus diese wechselwirkung
nachzuweisen um die existenz der schwere
wellen im inneren der sonne zu beweisen
und b aus den messergebnissen zu diesem
wechselwirkungen die geschwindigkeit der
kern rotation zu berechnen ihr plan ging
auf die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler entdeckten die
entsprechenden muster in den daten die
tatsächlich auf erschütterungen des
sonnen kerns durch schwere wellen
zurückzuführen sind
für ergebnis haben die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
direkt auch eine erklärung wie wohl
noch auf die frühzeit unseres
sonnensystems zurückzuführen ist als
sie vor etwa 4,6 milliarden jahren
entstand damals als sich die sonne im
zentrum der wolke bildete hatte sich
wohl zunächst genauso schnell gedreht
wie der rest der wolke dann allerdings
so mutmaßte forscherteam bremste der
starke sonnenwind die äußeren
schichten nach der zündung der
kernfusion ab die äußeren bereiche der
sonne wurden somit langsamer doch der
kern behielt seine schnelle rotation
neben dem wahrheit dafür dass schwere
wellen der sonne tatsächlich existieren
bedeutet die entdeckung also auch dass
die forscher relikte der sonne zur zeit
als sie entstanden ist aufgespürt haben
die neuen ergebnisse lassen aber nicht
nur rückschlüsse auf die entstehung
der sonne zu sondern werfen auch neue
fragen zum aufbau und zur evolution der
sonne auf wenn diese fragen beantwortet
werden dann werde ich euch hier klickst
du natürlich aus dem laufenden halten
wenn er kein video zu diesem thema und
auch zu allen anderen themen verpassen
wird wer hier ein abo aufs auge und
vergesst nicht den auf die glocke hier
geht es weiter hier mit dunkle materie
in der sonne entdeckt auch sehr sehr
spannend also nicht verpassen und
draufklicken und ansonsten bis dann
dann